last year President Trump took heat from
the left-wing mainstream destroyed Trump
media for referring to North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un as a little Rocket
Man remember this and by the way
Rocketman should have been handled a
long time ago
he should have been handled a long time
ago by Clinton I won't mention the
Republicans right by Obama why why did
this you know this is a different this
is a different time this should have
been handled eight years ago and four
years ago and honestly and 15 years ago
and 20 years ago and 25 years ago
this shouldn't be handled now but I'm
going to handle it because we have to
handle it
we remember at the time while people in
the media criticized the president's
tough rhetoric but it is clearly work
and now the summit is set for next month
during an interview on Face the Nation
our new Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
was asked to describe what struck him
about the North Korean dictator here's
what he said what struck me about it he
is very knowledgeable in the sense of he
knows the files he's very capable of
engaging in complex set of discussions
when I asked him a question about
something that's a little off he answers
it there's no notecards it is chairman
Kim in this case interacting with me
directly having a robust discussion
about what the outlines of a successful
negotiation between our two countries
might ultimately be he with reaction
former deputy assistant to the president
Fox News national security strategist
Sebastian Gorka and author of the
bestseller he's a friend we don't always
agree but he is my brother Geraldo
Rivera good to see both of you let me
start with you Geraldo on this because
I've always been a fan
Pompeyo is a genius I've been a fan of
his for a long time I'm glad he's our
Secretary of State and what he says to
me is very impressive but think about
this Trump calls him little Rocket Man
he shows military force he put sanctions
in place the rocket stopped being fired
the world is now safe for three hostages
are released he crosses the DMZ and
we're talking about denuclearizing or
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
you know what good story I'll say when
you consider how much we've traveled
since the Olympics just since the
Olympics you're on if I was a diplomat
I'd say I was caught
justly optimistic but I'm not a diplomat
and I'm not very diplomatic so let me
smell kidding
by diesel kidding we know you Q I'm
sorry I didn't mean no no that's it I
just I feel that you know we've moved so
far and Pompeyo is a very nuts-and-bolts
kind of guy it's not pie in the sky it's
not just wishful thinking on the part of
not at all of President Trump
these are real meaningful steps the
release of the hostages the the
announcement that in two weeks he'll be
blowing up the tunnels to his testing
facilities the fact that he's agreeing
to dismantle jinyo component parts to
Oak Ridge Tennessee I mean it is
spectacular Shawn if this is indeed what
is going to happen this is the biggest
move toward peace since the family of
the United Nations that and and
literally the alliance that has been
created by the president Israel the
Jordanians the Egyptians the Saudis the
Emirates against Iranian hegemony no
cargo planes the cash dr. Gorka a huge
difference it's amazing what difference
one election can make sure it truly is
these are the kinds of results you'd be
proud of at the end of a two-term
presidency I was in touch with Mike
Pompeo today spirits are very very high
we have to be cautious remember this is
a dictatorship this is a regime that has
kept its people prisoner but at the end
of the day you put the you put the in
these things on a white board in just 15
months all of these things have been
achieved it would have been remarkable
to have a summit on Korean peace in
eight years time not next week or the
week after so stunning you know from
from the 70th birthday of what the
modern Israeli state today to the
opening of the embassy the hits just
keep on coming
Geraldo I will say this between that
pulling out of the Iranian deal the
great news on the economy everything in
between I mean all the noise I argue is
not going to mean a thing when it comes
to 2018 election I believe this election
will be about the economy doing so much
better a world being a safer place a
president keeping his promises and
desire to rollback tax cuts and impeach
this president will be on the ballot in
every congressional district you know
it's interesting that you say that I I
agree and you know who else agrees the
New York Times Week in Review had an
article that I thought was very very
telling
they said that liberals are so smug they
know it all they are so sure that they
have God on their side and that Trump is
the devil incarnate that they their
their attitude is going to lead them
down the primrose path Trump President
Trump is doing a spectacular job with
the economy as you mentioned
african-american unemployment Hispanic
unemployment of female unemployment all
indicators of optimism everything
pointed up if he can now deliver this a
true denuclearized Korean Peninsula
unbeli clock the atom of the atomic
clock that ticks toward midnight will
have to be set back five ten minutes it
is like really a profound step in the
right direction Sean
we give dr. gore caleche work Sean er
Aldo the president makes promises he
keeps promises and this is what making
America great again
looks like and we're gonna have seven
more years of it and then eight years of
president pence
what about president Geraldo I thought
he was running writes these stories
about me nobody knows me all right that
well you two know me thank you both we
appreciate